all right let's jump into this first
story from the wall street journal
georgia guidestones monument damaged
embalming mysterious granite structure
which has drawn tourists to rural towns
since 1980 was intentionally bombed
authorities say take a look at that
photo man
dude
i'm really curious as to
what they did
who did it
why they did it the georgia guidestones
for those that aren't familiar are
called the monument to globalism
it's got these like 10 rules for for
creating a perfect society like maintain
the earth's population at 500 million
guide what is it so what does it say
guide breeding or something guide
reproduction wisely
yeah i think guide reproduction actually
i think i have it i'm so curious who put
these up i am trying to guide
reproduction wisely so they've got
population control and eugenics right
there in the first two number three is
unite humanity with a living new
language what does that even mean i
thought that's was currency when i
mentioned currency at the beginning
because you said they didn't mention
currency in these 10
you know these 10 commandments or
whatever the hell they're supposed to be
but they say a living new language i
don't understand what that means other
than like a way of
communicating that's not words
is this
yeah something like tongue clicking his
hands finger snapping yes more like
changes and grows something that changes
and grows language does yeah that's it
it almost doesn't make sense
so i have a question right so this is
the kind of person who's going to be
ragging on the guide stones is not going
to be for the most part a democrat or
leftist they're probably going to shrug
and not know what it is there are
probably some anarcho-lefty types tanky
or communist types who don't like no
actually i take that back the tankies
probably love this stuff but there's
probably some anarcho-lefty types who
don't like the idea of globalism for
sure or at least the way they've
described it but typically it's going to
be more right-wing individuals who know
what this is and don't like it
so whoever did this maybe a false flag
maybe someone who's actually mad about
globalism my question is
the critics of this are predominantly
going to be right-wing is this the first
statue or monument that's been taken
down that was predominantly criticized
by the right
i mean we've seen christopher columbus
we've seen washington didn't complain
and whine about it and protest they just
took it down well i mean the left
just takes stuff down exactly like they
just show up randomly and throw ropes
and then rip it down sure but they make
a big show of it they don't do it in the
dead of night that's interesting or they
have the access though to the power
structure to take it down
yeah somebody's listening at a
university or somebody's listening
downtown because they have the ear of
the government the right doesn't really
they want to make the authority comply
with their orders yeah you know what you
know what i thought about what took so
long
honestly in the era that we're in oh for
real yeah in 08 this thing was
vandalized they wrote all 2014 it was
vandalized 2014 again i am isis right in
2014 something ridic but now in this era
uh where anti-globalism is mainstream
you know maybe back in the era of obama
it wasn't as mainstream as it is now so
almost 2000 it was mainstream the left
was protesting the world trade
organization well right yep in this way
yeah right in this way where it's almost
a political force you know where uh
they had some kind of symbol that they
needed to go after it's almost like this
one was at the top of that list
um
and there haven't been with all the
anger out there that i see even in
poland with all the anger out there
there hasn't been as many events as i
thought there would be or you would
expect there to be because it feels like
people are getting to a point where
they're bubbling over
and they there there's just nowhere for
them to go to air these grievances
anymore so eventually we're just gonna
see stuff like this and that's uh we
don't know who did it yet but you know i
also think that klaus schwab is now in
the news pretty predominantly i didn't
even know he was two years ago world
economic forums all over the place the
black black rock black stone buying up
the houses is like trending on twitter
people are
are becoming aware that there is a
global corporation attempting to take
control of the united states and every
country on earth because
the nationalist governments are not
capable of governing themselves they
need the corporation according to klaus
he's crazy he's pretty good
yeah thank you we have this tweet from
the georgia bureau of investigation
showing this vehicle the gbi is
releasing surveillance video from this
morning's explosion that destroyed the
georgia guidestones
strange
they just installed surveillance cameras
they recently did so shane cashman of
tales from the inverted world he wrote
he went down to georgia he did this big
investigation he went to the guidestones
and he said they recently put in these
these floodlights and cameras and then
this happens
it's like
you you mentioned this just a second ago
why did it take so long right yeah and
then why did it happen right after the
cameras got installed and
where's the rest of it yeah they show
the car and they're like here's the car
but they don't show anything else they
just show
an explosion
fortunately nobody was around nobody got
hurt but it's very strange and then they
show the rubble it looks like they lined
that stone with explosives like they
didn't just blow up the base of it it
looks like it got blown apart by like uh
yeah a bunch of explosions it looks
possible it looks i mean i don't want to
use the word pro
but it doesn't that's not that doesn't
look like amateur hour to me i think it
actually looks amateur does it really
yeah because it only took out one of the
pillars
only because the blast didn't hit it if
you if if you look at it it looked like
it it went down melon that could be a
sign it is amateur but right it
disproportionately came out one end if
they put it in the center
wouldn't it have taken out the center
column it looks like it was placed in
front of one yeah so it doesn't seem pro
at all unless they didn't expect it to
be hazardous i've never seen a break and
you know yeah hit one the middle column
hit one side more than the other maybe
they expected it to
you know come out almost symmetrical but
it didn't i wonder why they decided to
demolish the rest of it
safety reasons i mean
it could be teetering it could collapse
you know so it looked pretty ragged
after lawsuits somebody
know right they paid to maintain this
like people would go out and clean up
and all that stuff the guide stones
actually had a bunch of other features
like if you looked through at a certain
angle or something it could show you
where the celestial pole was
there was like math on it multiple
languages
there was um
explanations for weights and
measurements why would they think this
would survive nuclear war i don't know
it's just stones right stone challenge
it's so long
idiots
seriously but i mean think about it the
first two things are population control
eugenics yeah they're idiots yeah well
of course
let me read some of this for you one let
me let me show you two of the ones a
couple of them that i really love
all right let's see
um rule passion faith tradition and all
things with tempered reason okay
i guess that's not telling anyone
anything though
because people all have different ideas
of what it means to be reasonable but
fine okay okay okay
all right
unite humanity within with a living new
language that explains nothing to no one
no who who is going to see them go oh i
get it no no no but it gets better
so it says nine prize truth beauty love
seeking harmony with the infinite what
what
this is written by people that have
enough food to eat
for sure yup yup that's that's
absolutely it i like number six
avoid petty laws and useless officials i
agree with that one let's go yeah they
stole number eight from thomas jefferson
they just they just twisted you know
they simplified what he said interesting
but that's what he used to say
you have no right that doesn't have an
equal or greater social duty as per
ian's point i'm imagining like nuclear
bombs fall
everything's wiped out and then some
dude with like a big beard and like a
stick walks up and he starts looking at
it and he like feels it and he goes oh
my stars turns around and starts
butchering some random person to eat
their corpse yeah really he's like
and then he's walks away and starts
hacking kids down
look at this let all this is number six
let all nations rule internally
resolving external disputes in a world
court i dig it that's like a a global
corporation
to rule everyone as a court
who appoints the court exactly the
countries i actually did that
unfortunately i like that one whose
country is you know the united states
gets to do what it wants we're sovereign
we you know stay out we mind our own
that goes without saying but instead of
war we have lost that's not how it works
we could try to do that but this just
gives us some weird
world court authority we should try to
have a court overshooting each other in
the face we have the u.n but we still
have like ukraine right
i think war it's inevitable because
even you know you have like uh you have
regular court you have civil courts
someone will be like that guy kicked my
dog i'm gonna pay for it and the guy
says no i didn't and then the other guy
shows up afterwards and punches him in
the face it's like you have we have
courts
disputes are still not always resolved
sometimes people still just get into a
fight so i'm i think world courts are a
good thing you know but you know inside
our country we do our thing
here's the issue
if the world court rules against you in
a way that's extremely unjust the unsure
is real you get war the world course
sometimes trans-pacific partnerships
investor state dispute settlement clause
where they were like a a global arbiter
will decide if if the american people
choose not to buy malaysian oil a world
tribunal will decide if the american
people can be sued and have to pay with
tax money to pay this corporation back
for their buying here's the real issue
that was a real proposal the idea of
some kind of global federalism where the
countries are sovereign but there is a
very weak central power that can mediate
never gonna happen what will happen is
the moment you enact a world court it'll
be just like the us's the federal
government will keep you surfing power
and then eventually you're in a
globalist authoritarian regime with
their boot on your neck
and then they're going to come to your
country and be like you lost the lawsuit
you can't use carbon anymore
yeah that's it's going to come down and
coalitions are going to come together to
to you know basically take the balance
of that court or try to influence it um
in the end it would probably end up just
like i mean i'm not saying it's not
worth trying but it might probably would
just end up
like the u.n does i mean we have it
depends i might be all right with this
if
if if we laid out the ground rules for
how who would be the arbiter so i don't
want some arbitration panel of elitists
up there making up the rules how would
we select these i think people i think
there's no real way to do it reasonably
because
people's values gosh dramatically the us
values clash with china in ways that are
just irreconcilable absolutely so what's
going to happen is i'll we'll use elon
musk as an example elon is going to buy
twitter right he said you know i'm
moderate i think the good compromise is
that both sides are unhappy and i'm like
oh okay that's how things are
the left wants the right band completely
the right doesn't care the left speaks
so the compromise is okay we'll ban some
of the right well that's not fair
so actually we'll talk about this in a
minute too
the uh andrew schultz for instance
yeah you know he did this comedy bit
netflix apparently wanted him to pull
some jokes and he refused and it's like
you listen to it you're like oh he's
making fun of both sides and it's like
yeah kind of but not really because the
right is okay with the jokes this is
this is the problem there's not going to
be a fair court you'll have the united
states being like we're totally cool
that china does their thing so long as
they don't come here then china's gonna
be like we're not cool that they're
doing their thing and the world court's
gonna be like okay we'll compromise the
u.s has to give up some of its rights
that's how it would play out unless you
get aggressive so i don't think i don't
i think
federalism the idea sounds beautiful
i don't know how you protect against
you know massive acceleration of uh the
coalescing of power
well the united states constitution is a
decent archetype for it
but
i don't know man to extrapolate that to
the globe it's like a fantasy of mine
yeah because you want to push your
values on other people who just don't or
not even push them on other people you
wanted others to see the value
of
the ideas that are in the constitution
but they they just some just won't it
would be pushing my values yeah it would
be forcefully providing american
democracy and republicanism to the world
overthrowing monarchs you know upending
totalitarian governments and giving the
people freedom yeah if they thought the
world was going to end in a nuclear
holocaust
so they made these stones
and said you got to keep 500 million
people that's the limit
and then
no nuclear holocaust happened
did they just decide you don't have to
have 500 million people anymore or do
they still hold that value and think
okay well now we got to do it i don't
think the 500 million should be set in
stone lol
just like
in the constitution one representative
represented 30 000 people that number
was destined to change they just wrote
it down there at the beginning because
that made sense at that moment at that
moment this doesn't say like and this
number can change they don't
they don't become seems arbitrary it is
500 million yeah some someone in the 80s
there's a lot of questions around who
actually put it up why why are there
questions around who put this up it was
put up in 1980 right yeah there's no way
there's not still
oh it's a bunch of rich people okay that
actually creepy people who think they're
smarter than you and there and lies the
big problem oh there you go there's a
video going viral
um it's a bunch of climate change
activists block a highway yeah and then
this guy gets out and he's like yo i
gotta get to work i'm on parole they're
gonna lock me up if i don't get to work
and they'd ignore him and then he walks
up to the person like give me one lane
just let me get to work oh i'm gonna get
locked up and they just tell him no like
it's the craziest thing to watch
this guy tweeted he's like i'll testify
in his bf i'm sorry that he got arrested
you know but whatever and then he's like
ask ask the activists organizers what we
should have done and i'm like you people
are evil that's what evil looks like
that
they think they're smarter than you they
think they're better than you they think
they're more righteous than you and when
you beg them please i don't want to go
to prison they just they just look you
and say i don't care i literally don't
care it's fascinating man
they think they're the righteous ones
the people who put up those stones are
exactly that
they think they know better than you and
they don't they never do that's why you
can't allow this kind of
authoritarianism because you get some
guy who's like i'm smarter than everyone
everyone melt down all your tools and
make iron
kill all the sparrows they're hurting
the crops and then you get famine and
destruction and starvation that's how it
goes
you get these people who are like i
think the farmers should own the farms
kill the landowners and then everyone
starves to death because the farmers
don't actually know how to run and
maintain the farm that's what happens
every time do not let these people who
think they're smarter you take over
decentralization is the only way to
properly maintain
well do we know if the people who set
these up actually did any of the things
that they were talking about there's a
lot of talk and a weird monument no i
don't know who set it up yeah they're
still alive probably yeah i hope that
they speak out i'm looking at the
wikipedia in 2008 the stones were
defaced with polyurethane paint with
explosions such as death to the new
world order
that's what it said in a way yeah and i
am isis or something in 2014 right yeah
i am isis goddess of love yeah
the rest of that was that's right
because i just saw it a little bit ago
um
after seeing this happen uh i looked at
it and i i kind of remember some of
these stories
but i i don't i don't look at them as i
look at a story like this now or i
didn't because you know the struggle uh
that we're seeing society right now i
guess uh
is not as
voc it's but more vocalized now it's
more in party platforms now than it was
before uh so i guess that's why my
initial thought was what it was because
we know people have had these
frustrations in the past but now they're
coming to life and
it's not a small you know they would be
kind of put off to the side awesome nut
cases vandalized it you could read how
the washington post tweeted this story
will summers how he laid it out on
twitter even before he got into anything
the first thing out of his mouth was you
know this has really been for a long
time the target of these right-wing
conspiracy nuts that's how you choose to
lead in this story
which goes to show you he's one of those
people
he's exact that is him and he gives his
hand away by even coming out with it
like that in the first place um thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there
you